would it be nice
well with me it was a terrible time
because my breathing symptoms started
with the temperature shortage of breath
healthcare systems everywhere have been
overwhelmed with coronavirus patients
here's how hospitals around the world
are dealing with mounting challenges we
can't cope with a big spike we just
we're planning for many more patients so
all our theatres to be full of care with
patients and possibly beyond it is we
have a full ICU we have every patient in
here on a ventilator
everybody has coronavirus some people
also have heart attacks at the same time
this happens medical professionals are
still scrambling for supplies in Italy
even as the number of new cases begins
to level out the country still has one
of the largest and most deadly
coronavirus outbreaks to te operatory
sanitary della Lombardi Adele Italia to
toe so stati prácticamente la chaleur Oh
Stacey : misery and columnist Karina
without protection doctors are scared in
Peru
hospitals are also experiencing a lack
of equipment the country has almost
10,000 cases as of April 14th percent
ASEAN ASEAN positive OHS esta empezando
se para el Hospital sin tener siquiera
Mon atención por que ninguna eco teen
attend our loss porno tener la Renta
lament a go equipo de protección
personal por el NiO acontecer nostril
you're gonna hear a familiar song
history whoo as of April 14th Spain has
the second highest number of cases the
country is right behind the u.s. at over
a hundred and seventy thousand more than
15% of health care workers in Spain have
been infected by the corona virus over
four thousand miles away in India train
carriages are being transformed into
isolation wards we have removed the
middle buds and the one laboratory of
Indian style which is locked and
converted to the shower room where the
waiting facility to be done for doctors
nurses and also for patients sanitizing
tunnels are also popping up at local
hospitals to spray disinfectants as
people pass through them the country
with its high population of 1.3 billion
has about one public hospital bed per
patient mildly symptomatic patients in
Tokyo are being moved from healthcare
systems to hotels the dense City has
been scrambling to find more hospital
beds an international fair area in
northern Iraq has been converted into a
250 bed hospital while hospitals provide
a space to battle the corona virus it's
the medical professionals who are on the
frontlines and some are trying to remain
positive on one hand I left my kids at
home so that I could go and fight this
war along with my colleagues but on the
other hand I feel optimistic I feel
hopeful because as a critical care
physician this is what we've trained for
we know that this is what we have to do
and we know that we're well equipped to
do it
no no no she ended up a job
so start with a load of a pension you
aren't able to tell thing ever likely to
be lasting finale thanks okay took you
under a station I could subtract a and
she chose not to tell about the game
kappa there are lava charged with me
[Music]